throughout the years you've been in so
many iconic roles you've done so many
great performances and you would think
Oh John let's go has an unerring sense
of what's a good role that is not the
case always don't like like most great
actors there's that role every now and
then that you turn down that might haunt
you a little bit for example I found out
recently that Tim Burton when he was
doing the first great Batman movie when
in the in the late 80s came to you and
talked to you about doing the role of
the Joker and you talked him out of it
exactly foolish man I know I I was
acting on Broadway at the time in M
butterfly and exhausted all the time as
an incredibly hard role Marian Doherty
the great casting director who did all
of his casting who cast me in world
according to GARP yeah said see
Beetlejuice come in meet this bright
young man Tim Burton I will have taken
him to the show the night before you
know she just laid it out on a silver
platter and I came into that room sort
of ashen-faced and tired and persuaded
Tim Burton not to hire me or even think
about me as the Joker now granted
ultimately he probably would have had
the choice between me and Jack Nicholson
and it would have been a slam dunk but I
sat there and said our self out of even
being considered and you know why I
figured who's gonna want to go to see a
movie about Batman many like an
butterfly
exactly that's what the kids like to see
I actually had the conscious thought
that's why I I do that all the time it's
why my career never quite took off yeah
right yeah yeah that's right your poor
crappy career